I promised myself I was going to deal
with ocean issues and it's really hard
it took me six months to come up with an
approach to even thinking about it like
how do you I don't want to do Weiland
you know how can I be dispassionate
about these creatures because I I don't
want to make nature art that's you know
Lions in the sunset and all that kind of
stuff I'm doing it for a different
reason I want it to last and I also
build it so that I can let projects like
this use the images to have projects
like this happen this is a record that
was made by you know now I can't I don't
have my glasses on so I can't even see
who was done by apologies but it's
recordings of animals that are on the
rise and animals that are on the descent
so I like using these images for for
political purposes it's okay so back to
oceans they're huge how am I ever gonna
parse it you know all the other things
I've had like a logical pathway to get
to the subject matter and oceans are so
big and overwhelming and all the
creatures have all these body parts and
I don't know what they're for
so I decided that the rubric would be
they need to be everywhere they need to
be plentiful they need to be in all the
oceans and they need to be relatively
unknown by the general populace and oh
that's a good thing I can contribute
that so new to banks was the first one I
decided to do it I spent about know at
least a year learning about them before
I even start painting every nudibranch
is a hermaphrodite
they have both sets of equipment this is
to sort of standard new tube ranks
mating they will both go off and lay
eggs so they have both both sets and
they can they practice protandrous so
they don't have to be the same age
bracket they can be there can be a great
big one and a small one of the same
species and that's because they have a
really hard time finding each other
another side track to that is that
nudibranch penises are really weird
there's lots of Barb's and little cups
and things and every species is entirely
different and they're all kind of
designed so that okay we're together
we're not gonna let the tide blow us
apart and that's when I found out about
penile fencing so these are actually
head shield slugs there is still in the
osteo brank group very similar group H
is the head so we'll talk about the
lower animal because the other ones been
turned into a female the the penis goes
in like they do with all of them they go
side to side but where they fence is
with this second it's sort of like a
double a y-shaped thing the one on the
right the S thing is a like a hypodermic
needle and that's the part they fence
with they're each trying to stab the
other guy in the foot and the first guy
who stabs they inject a hormone which
makes the person who got injected first
turn into a female I mean the world is
so much stranger than I even give it
credit for and I see a lot of weird
stuff
[Music]